before he starts work freddie vergus
enjoys his mornings with his sons
these days the time is short-lived it's
not long before he receives his first
grocery order
as more people stay at home to curb the
spread of the virus
grocery delivery services are a popular
option the message from doctors
is to stay at home and avoid interacting
with people
but that's not possible for delivery
riders like him
i'm worried about the virus but what
choice do i have i have to feed my
family
all i can do is hope i don't get
infected
he's one of the millions delivering all
over indonesia's capital
despite having more orders since the
outbreak escalated
he has less income
i need the money we're not allowed to
take passengers anymore so i can only do
grocery and food deliveries
for food workers in indonesia and
globally it's a similar sentiment
[Music]
i'm scared of the coronavirus of course
but my income comes from sales
so i have no other option
i keep my distance with customers and i
clean my products
but if i don't keep working how can i
live
they're regarded worldwide as essential
workers but are low paid and can't
afford to stop working
even if they wanted to physical
distancing is only an option for those
who can afford it
and most in the food industry cannot
this workforce is essential in all
countries
year round but now they're at the
forefront of a global crisis
and their work comes with increased risk
simple tasks such as accepting change or
restocking shells
are now an infection threat
my company has given us clear
instructions we need to wash our hands
and wear a mask
i try to be fit wash my hands and i've
stopped going out
i don't want to get infected workers
like him do what they can to feel safe
and around the world billions rely on
them to get what they need
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta